Kevin Hart what's going on sup buddy hey
how's Jim how you doing man how you
doing man
I'm very well III set you a text I
didn't hear back so he's fighting again
I read oh he got it the majority of your
book I read did you like it it's I'm not
even being polite it's one of the best
biographies I've ever read Thank You Man
[ __ ] amaze Thank You Man I've written
50 pages on the way to Europe
I couldn't stop reading your blankey man
I know you a long time and there's so
much stuff about you I didn't know it's
a lot of it's a well first of all the
reason for writing the book was to vet
you know I think there's a lot of levels
to and I hate to go third-person to the
the individuals Kevin Hart you know and
I think what I want to do is share
information that can be valuable to
people in their journey you know or
their road to success in whatever it is
that you're doing
I think information is key and so many
people hate to share information so many
people are selfish with information I
think my role is a road of hardship you
know so it's a lot of [ __ ] that I
went through to get to where I am today
a lot of violence you saw I didn't know
you saw that kind of violence growing up
yeah yeah my dad my dad was a cookie man
because uh here's a cab he did a lot so
I saw your father he was bleeding from
being hacked up with an axe my dad I had
to have an axe what when I went over his
house to go see him which my mom hated
to do because her fare was we don't know
what happened over there and one of the
times when she was like fine go
my dad got in a fight the guy hit my dad
in here with ax he came back with a tile
tile was ful fully blood like visit no
white left in the town that had a
logical explanation and that was
refrigerator repairman yeah right it was
that's another an idea in frigerator of
a [ __ ] I was just because I was better
and he hit me with the axe do you think
that's the real reason oh how absolutely
not but back then when you're a kid it
makes sense oh yeah oh god dad well you
got to stop being so good in
refrigerator she just wanted to take the
opportunity get yourself a pat on the
back like that
and literally like I mean between that
between sitting seeing my dad get jumped
me and my brother saw my dad get jumped
and before happening that y'all go home
I'm about to whoop these guys ass
clearly knew that it was gonna go the
other way
you think he won't be with the rest no
getting back came back in the results
are obvious maybe what happened he got a
feelings he didn't even acknowledge it
he's like y'all hungry like look at you
man y'all don't hear you when you see
your father get your father's like such
a strong figure in your life and does it
scare you when you see a strong figure
like that be beaten up it's it's a
different level of reality as a child
like your dad is a hero you know there's
nothing that your dad can't do your dad
say you can do it as a kid you believe
if I say hey y'all want to see me jump
on this roof yeah I brush everybody back
up
what I do is not my kids and only people
I did it's like dad's gonna do it yeah
they have nothing but belief that you
can do what you say you can do so when
you start to see the the guy that you
saw that was instant invincible in your
mind you start to see those layers get
peeled away it does have an effect you
know it is like damn like dad is not who
we thought dad was not a superhero yeah
live them steel yes a lot of [ __ ] in the
other you just like your dad was just
amazing refrigerator repairman who beat
everybody up they're like no he's not no
he's not no he's just our lead a dad
does drugs and steals refrigerators it
might a complete opposite my favorite
part about the beginning it seemed like
you're like your childhood was very
confusing because I got a lot of the
stories as I'm reading them I feel like
I kind of know where they're going to go
and then they just go in a completely
table direction
yeah like when your dad's driving you to
school and he goes you know son you're
gonna be okay and I'm like oh that's
gonna be one of those sweet stories and
he goes because you know we all got long
did we got exists that is a true piece
of advice that my dad gave me like I was
just like you run waiting for the gym I
was waiting for the piece of life that
my dad was by the drop on me and he's
like we got big dick
I got like dick your brother got a big
dick so you gotta have a big dick
so we gonna be okay I wish my father
gave me advice like that
I heard like Kevin [ __ ] way back
chief Robinson
he said his dick got thrown out of the
room when Kevin showed Evans right he
did gross [ __ ] yeah okay yeah yeah
that's a bit hard more that's true
annoys me is very true really I will
just say that there's one time at the
Comedy Cellar that he showed it to a
waitress who requested it and she came
up oh my god oh my god it really is true
and that was uh that confusing moment
comes back and you're like dad's right
I'm gonna be okay okay I'm gonna be all
right I didn't know what he meant by
back then but but here's what that helps
you a yeah your confidence is always is
always at a high level because you know
something that people don't know yes
people you are very confident in people
look at you like you shouldn't be yeah
but you are interesting really long
before same long before money you're a
confident guy although it's countless
and your mother Julie I understand a lot
more about you after reading this
because you you really are a hard worker
I mean you're always doing something
you're always motivated you're not
asking anybody to do anything and make
it happen for you you're doing it yes
and then I see how you were raised with
your mom and how she kind of didn't let
you do anything and had a kid say oh now
that kind of makes sense your mother
really my mom was strict my mom was very
strict but she's also she was strict
simply because she saw the mistakes that
she made with my brother she was more
lenient with my brother you know my
brother was able to go out and come and
go as he pleased you know there was a
curfew but it was late and that's where
my brother was in the streets my brother
sold drugs my brother was stealing at
one point you know snatching purses and
robbing people at gunpoint he got caught
up into a bad life as well so with me it
was no yeah you're not doing anything
you're not going anywhere you're not
going to leave my sight I'm going to put
you in an extracurricular activity that
takes up all your time
that's why swimming came about it's all
right yeah you swam for year him I swim
from the edge like eight or nine until
the end of high school so I never had
free time I didn't have room for errors
and that's what she made sure of she
didn't want me on the streets at all she
didn't want me to become a product of my
environment she didn't want me
to grow up like my dad and I mean I was
tough on her because ultimately you grow
a little bit of hate you grow some
resentment as like yo you don't let me
do nothing like and why don't you let me
see Dad and she got tired of hearing
that so I remember the baggage the
biggest lesson she took me was you know
she's like you know what you want to see
your dad you want to go live with your
dad cause I kept saying I'm a runaway
I'm gonna live with dad I want to be
anymore
you know you get to the age yeah as a
boy growing pretty puberty then kicked
in tighter you treat me like I'm a boy
I'm a man man hey you know I'm 16 house
me a hole my own industry she lay you
gonna live with your dad do you know
what go go all right fine fine
I can go go get your stuff go I will dad
mom so I can come live with you come on
leave my dad you know has no question
come on he didn't do it she didn't do
any checking I didn't want to know where
my son was didn't let him know if I had
an extracurricular activity anything
that I needed to know if I would do it
has none of that come on I get to my dad
house this is a true story my dad had
about seven or eight people living in
this place I didn't know any of them
there was no electricity they had a plug
and it was like a cord that was hooked
up and ran from like an abandoned house
on there was still in electricity so the
electricity came from somewhere else
there was no hot water and to take a
bath there was no like cover made me
like put water and a basin and he was
like put the water in the basin and heat
it up next to the kerosene heater and
they used the base in the washer and it
was like just a worse living condition
that I've seen now granted for my dad
and the people there that environment
was comfortable that's all they knew but
I was like wait where's the tub where's
my bed you know I was on a couch and
with other people around the couch and
I'm like what the [ __ ] home where did at
least meeting well-kept no no not at all
and I remember calling my mom that same
night and I was like
you gotta come get me she's like the
hell I do you want to live with your dad
live with your dad and I was like well I
don't want to live with dad anymore I
didn't know the dad was listening like
this no you know everything what I'm
doing is wrong
so that's what you want and that's what
you going get she made me stay there
tonight
and that was like one of the toughest
nights and I have nothing but love for
my dad but it was just tough because I'm
like who are these people and looking
where I'm at like I'm on account I'm not
even comfortable and my mom came to get
me the next day and it was basically if
you're gonna live under my roof you're
gonna live by my rules
okay stop battling me stop thinking that
I'm doing was wrong for you what I'm
thinking I'm doing was right and she
never down talked my dad and never never
made me feel like my dad was an enemy or
like he was doing these wrong things
she's always big my father because he's
my father but she allowed me to see
things on my home as I got older you
ever resent him like did you ever get
mad at kids there's some stories about
your dad in the book that are really
kind of staggering yeah yeah yeah I
never I never resented my dad that's a
tough word um never I never I don't have
any level of hate you know of course
there was disappointment there was high
levels of dam I thought dad was coming
to pick us up today or damn man what I
ain't seen dad and I don't know how long
you're not picking the phone he's not
answering the calls you know there's a
there's a level of what's going on with
dad it was never a thing where it was
like my dad any [ __ ] I don't I don't
have that many I never have and my mom
never talked like that to help ignite a
flame that would put that in me so when
he went through his problems he went
till morning on until my brother felt
that I was old enough to handle
information and he told me dad's on
drugs it is what it is you know we can't
help him so he wants to help himself and
my dad had resentment and a grudge
because my dad stole from my brother you
know my brother was building his
barbershop and he brought all the
equipment he wanted my dad to do the
electrical work just to kinda help you I
get back actually helped him get on his
feet because the money in his pocket and
my dad was doing the job for a minute
and then we
come back one day everything was gone my
dad stole everything and as my brother
didn't like it went black for my brother
after day so it took me talk to my
brother to get my brother to forgive so
we can finally get my dad and help so
you look at all this stuff and people
who think like all Kevin just trying to
came in and you didn't have it easy
coming up now you have it you didn't get
handed a deal when you came into the
business and you were in the business
for quite a while before anything
happened a long time mean I got 19 years
almost 20 years in the business so what
what gave you that patience because like
you said around you it was a lot of
culture of quick money your dad stealing
your brother selling drugs like you saw
people not being patient about it like
no I'm 16 I'm a man I can go I can no
drugs I can steal I can do this I can
get money right now and be the man and
that doesn't really match up with you
know driving in New York to do comedy
yeah well you know I saw you see the
consequences of a first hand you know I
saw I saw my dad in and out of jail you
know I saw my dad being addicted to
drugs so my brothers sell drugs so my
mom find drugs and beat the [ __ ] on my
brother and my brother be forced with an
ultimatum of jail or the army like pick
one and he chose the army of course I
saw literally no high reward from the
negatives bro I saw that I saw it
firsthand
so when it was time for me to make
decisions the one person that I saw with
any type of consistency was my mom you
know it's not - my mom was Richard not
my mom was successful and financially
stable on a high level my mom did what
she had to do to make sure that we were
taken care of
and you know those lifestyles were not
cheap granted where we lived the cost of
living wasn't crazy so when I say not
cheap I'm saying I was on a swim team I
was very expensive we had to travel we
had to there was hotels there was bus
rides there were you know car pools
there was different different levels of
fees that come up you know it's a
traveling national swim team but she's
doing all this to keep you out of the
streets
keep you from getting [ __ ] up outside
Dallas all of it was done on my side all
done myself
you mean I laughed out loud reading when
you were talking about stupid teeth and
you said that he says he told you your
name little was it will you little keV
at that point yeah look at the bad
little keV the best we told the first
thing tells you that your name is awful
and you pointed out how he had the worst
version of a name is awful stupid anger
the words the words tone on a human
voice that I've ever heard like I've
never heard anybody talk like that I
thought it was a joke I've gotta be
joking I got a voice box and this is the
truth
you reminded me to men of how cruel
Lucian was from the comedy I'm from the
comic strip you know he's dead now so we
don't want to speak ill of the dead but
I don't like the guy I don't think he
was a good guy I think he was there was
an honesty to him but there was an
unnecessary level of cruelty to people
he liked being mean to comedians he
liked being [ __ ] cutting and vicious
under the guise of being honest he I
mean I mean that's the first guy to hit
me with my honestly that was my first my
first rib shot you're not saying we all
take body blows in the entertainment
business you there's always something
that happens that makes you go oh like
damn like there's a there's moments
where you got to take to me Lucian was
the first person to put me down to where
I had taken me he was he was basically
he told me that I needed to find
something else to do you know it was
that blunt I got offstage I had a great
set you know granted my material wasn't
great material I'm new I'm green but I
had a great set the crowd enjoyed me and
I thought that I was going to the back
to talk to him about coming to the comic
strip and doing spots and instead it was
just I don't see it I don't see this
being your craft you know I think that
you should definitely look into doing
something else because this isn't this
isn't it this isn't this isn't for you
and that's the first time that I heard
that but I had a guy like Keith that I
was so close to that I told him and I'm
expected kissing like damn as lucious
said that it's something and keep it
like I
[ __ ] Lucian so what come on stupid let's
go down to the cellar get some meat and
I was like
eat I can't at a time like this my life
is over shut up stupid he's getting a
car and we'll go to other comedy club
[ __ ] pollution like he was so it was so
nonchalant and it rolled off his back
and when I saw that I was like I was
still affected by it but I was like no
no ha like there's no big deal this is
me this is my career it is a big deal
then we get down to the cellar and
everybody there is just so what whatever
and we all are so vicious to each other
and we always so mean to each other but
what we really did was prepare each
other for the word knowing I could come
in any possible time we made other
comfortable with the fact that we we
were ok we're going to be ok and we're
and it's also like the guys like we
would attack each other and it's all
hack court but you only did that with
guys you liked and respected and guys
you genuinely thought were fine it was
like nobody took a guy who was really a
bad comedian and just sat in there and
attacked it would feel like attacking
audience member yes so the guys that we
took the hack court like we all we all
drop bits you've no one ever wanted half
court no way no one ever there's like
like that court in Batman now when you
can either get killed or you have to
walk in the in the across the [ __ ]
frozen river so anyway it's never going
to be like you know what that was
actually a good joke we're incorrect
never never you would never come out of
hat course right no we're never coming
out with people going down now guys
that's a good bit I remember arguing
y'all down about the [ __ ] bit I had a
[ __ ] Domitian Robert F - [ __ ] Robert
and I thought that this bit was one of
the best events ever it was a bit about
how I got robbed by a [ __ ] it was a
cross-eyed [ __ ] and I didn't know he
was looking at me when he was robbing me
because he was cross-eyed right instead
of using the gun he chose the head but
me now grant is now now this is a sing
it out loud today I get I get where they
were come see me I refuse now yes I see
the Aaron way back then back then
there's no way that you can tell me that
me saying because the person was
cross-eyed
and I didn't know who he was robbing
that was the whole genius in the
business I like sure how does my
pleasure I was how else was no use
rather than me were you was looking at
him come on yes yes I get laughs so when
I tell you they be big joke so bad I
just wish people knew he can't make from
you repeat oh I'm a head court so I
don't rule out you have to testify in
your own defenders so he was like so let
me get you again
could you call me little dummy who's
robbing you again I kept going the
[ __ ] he's like right right back up
that back up to the beginning who has a
gun another committee is gonna make me
pay and every time I would say it he
would act like he was giant and he's
like this is why this joke stinks and he
was like the message the [ __ ] is not
funny it's not funny I was like what
about the cross-filing I thought this
joke so bad but I love that there was so
vicious man right I have nothing but
respect for Noren Voss Patrese Colin
Keith Berg I mean that table that table
of people that we put together man that
set and just joked in and cut and cut at
that made me so strong with the BS that
I eventually dealt with in LA it rolled
off my back I don't care and it makes
you more honest too because you're still
used to being called out and calling
people out that when something bad
happens instead of the room being
uncomfortable you're like oh that was
[ __ ] awful and you're okay
acknowledging it that was bad I mean SNL
man those impressions might not might
not make it hyung guys because I said
that vision that when I got done Avery
jobs and I was like no Avery Johnson
vans
how are your Janiero these sodas in your
own air was horrible
[Laughter]
screwing up my face I really don't even
say a line that dinero Dave in the movie
I just mmm
that's it I guess that was your gentle
any good no it was a fresh offer okay
okay okay that's it guys okay good I
remember I remember Lauren jizz eating
popcorn ball hmm hey ball fan hmm
another yellow hair some stand up it was
just the worst did you know you were
bombing I knew our bombing and the
impressions I killed understanding
please it when I got to the impressions
it was that's one at all when the
characters were going yeah that's enough
when I when I got to the part where you
had to show why you should be on the
show sure that's where I was I said the
stand up we had nothing to do with us
and now I'm a comedian but I cannot do
it precious God so I don't think I'm a
fit in here at all what was the show to
this is something I remember when you
got the show I didn't know this part of
it happened just so much [ __ ] I didn't
know you get this show and they're ready
it's on ABC mmm-hmm what was the name of
that show that was about when they were
going to be brought to New York to
announce it the big house that was the
big house big house uh people don't even
know this story man I got at a young age
thing was 24 maybe the thing was about
24 I had I does when I had had a deal I
went to Montreal did well got a deal
nothing happened and I said you know
what I said what I should do is develop
my own show what if I what if I had an
idea for a show telling my manager day
Becky he's I may not to be cool like
what's the idea and I pitched him the
idea I wanted to do the reverse of The
Fresh Prince of bel-air so basically
it's a guy who's coming from money
something happen with his parents and
he's forced to go back and live with his
other side of the family who's not doing
well at all this is how I wanted to do a
spin on my life and right about where I
came from I just wanted to have a reason
to get their pitch to show show gets
picked up oh my God my life is about to
change
I'm about to be rich I made it this is
crazy I got my own show I'm executive
producing I'm a writer on it I'm
starring in it they picked up 12
episodes this is unbelievable
okay Kevin you got to go to the upfront
it's a big deal
the up-front tell me what it is but
that's where we take the talent and they
go to New York and there's this big
thing where they announce to show in
front of people and you got to take
pictures it's like the best thing ever
oh my god do I get a suit get a suit
what about the rest of the cast
well they only want you there no that
can't be because I'm not doing the show
by myself you know what the Cavs got to
come they're not gonna fly the rest of
the cast here then I want to take my
money and do it you know I don't have a
crazy amount of money but I can afford
to fly them the show don't happen
without them right I'm flying the whole
casting through the whole cast to New
York put them in hotels myself up front
day walk out the hotel pictures man stop
I'm a star without your first experience
with that first experience with that I'm
a star man look as I'm walking on the
carpet my Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin Hart
hey the big house taking pictures the
most unbelievable feeling ever
I get there then I all right Kevin
you're going up you got about seven
minutes let's get you backstage to give
me backstage a wire me put the mic on me
I'm about to basically walk onstage and
they're gonna announce what's new for
this fall season the big house right
before I'm about to take a step there's
a guy in front of me he's just talking
and headset this is what I hear
verbatim mm-hmm I got him he's right
here yeah okay and then what okay no I'm
looking at it okay I'm gonna do it right
now
since we'll send the other one so I know
that way so they can go okay
all right Kevin you're not you're not
going up I said I'm sorry
do you mean no me neither you're not
you're not using you're not going up on
this one something's going on with it I
think they're pulling the show I don't
know but it sound like they're pulling
the show I'm sorry Dyslexic this is
crazy what what I'm so confused what to
step back step back and get a step back
okay
bring him up I see another show five
people they're just rushing me she was
in stage the hosts goals and the
McKinney's whatever to show calories or
something it was it was a I forgot that
I've got the act that he was short
there's only three show guys
white guy he had a show and it was
coming on there's neighbor recreating
TGIF they bring him up he Wizards Bob me
they're high-fiving they're excited Dave
is running I see Dave running back
sweating I don't know where he ran from
sweating he's like buddy don't panic I
don't know what this is I've never seen
anything like this in the business this
has never happened I'm going to get to
the bottom of this right now okay don't
worry about it I'm like what's going on
right now they're trying to pull some
[ __ ] so trying to say you're cancelled
okay what what ha I never what do you
mean I'm Kent I know I know it's crazy
we're gonna get to the bottom of it just
know that I'm on it man Dave go to the
back he said let's get out of here let's
go to hotel he's on the phone
everybody's talked to that I know I know
it's cancer if it's cancer
they basically cancel the show nobody
from the network came to talk to me
nobody confronted me nobody said
anything I said what about the cast I
flew the cast out here David I I'm I'm
trying to fight figure it out man
they're saying that they don't want to
fly them back you know because they
didn't fly them out I'm like what the
[ __ ] oh my god I gotta tell the cash so
I have a meeting with the cast about how
I through everybody else how the show's
not getting picked up it's canceled I'm
sorry guys I'm gonna try to find out
what I can
I booked you guys flight so you can get
out of here they're down there
disappearing it
I said enjoy the rooms just you know in
the morning you guys can jump on the
plane cast flies out Dave goes do you
want to go home I can have them change
the flight so you can leave I know this
is tough I said I'm not going anywhere
I said it's my first time ever
experienced anything like this I'm going
to parties I'm going to every party like
I'm have a good time I went to every
single party everybody looked at me like
I was crazy they don't know what how all
knew what happened it spread like
wildfire and it was like he's got to be
on drugs or something like how can he be
having a good time everybody's just kind
of checking on me you okay we heard what
happened I'm like I'm fine
it is what it is there's life you know
hopefully I get the next one I was
prepared for that punch in the stomach
because I was already taking so many
punch
in the stomach right this was a big
punch in the stomach but I had so many
that I shoulder shrug it I'm gonna be
alright I'll be back I was actually
telling that to people to execs to
studio heads I'm good I'll be back it's
just the first time man it's the first
of many I was so positive that everybody
was mind blown
that when things finally turned around
and I did come back because I ended up
picking the show up later that year and
he picked us up for like six episodes
everybody was so happy at the
opportunity they were rooting go kevin
was so glad that they finally worked out
was so glad six episodes show got
cancelled again I was okay alright fine
I guess I gotta figure out a way to
create another show I'd be alright
but those same studio execs are still in
the business today so the respect and
admiration that they have for me for
taking it the way to that dish or has
played a major part in the opportunities
that I get today because my person was
never in question you talk about that
like in the book a couple of times even
when you're a kid you say you have this
ability to take these shitty things that
happen and just brush them off like you
talked about that we will talk about the
resentment like all this stuff you don't
carry negative stuff with you and all I
could think is do you worry that you're
carrying it it's all buried I don't and
then at some point it's all going to
explode what it exploded already they
came out if that was the case it was Ben
came out I mean I would I be waiting for
you know I lost my mother I mean I dealt
with the craziest stuff that I could
deal with from my dad and how's he doing
by the way my dad's an opener oh really
oh good were living in the house brought
my dad a house car he's fine cuz he's
gonna live is he - yeah he you know I
mean if you really look back at the
things that I've overcome it would have
come out you know at this point I know
why I'm able to show the shrug things
and people got choices I hate that
people act like they don't have a choice
you know you got a choice in any and
everything you do here's one thing that
I'll say to your listeners and when I
say just think about it do you know how
much energy and time it takes to be
angry do you know how much time it takes
to hold a grudge - really
muster up the energy to hold on to a
grudge I don't like you every time I see
you I gotta let you know unlike you I
don't like energy right yeah that I'm
doing I'm throwing all this stuff I'm
throwing all this stuff ye away and
that's energy that I could use to go
into something else like I when I think
about my time I think about my energy I
think about my effort how much time and
energy do I really have and how much do
I want to put into stuff that's not
going to affect me on a day-to-day basis
negative just nonsense nonsense I mean
would I don't have the time for it
that's why the negativity that the
negativity that I had received I'm a
smile with kindness I get hate all the
time again I'm always amazed a comedians
by the way who looks exact opposite for
what yeah like you work like I
understand a certain comments that other
comedians don't like but you're not one
of them and I'm like guys who are
jealous like one guy was it was bashing
you call yah he's all social media and
this guy's over a million Twitter
followers
you're not exactly anonymous dude just
doing it's it's a thing where you have
to understand that some people just
don't know how to genuinely be happy for
personal success I know how to be happy
for me I'm not in competition with
anybody I'm not a competition with
nobody I'm in competition with myself
I'm confident trying to evolve I'm
constantly putting in the work to
progress and build up a catalogue that
can be looked at as Kevin Hart's legacy
I'm get ready to do another tour so I
can have another hour special I said
well how many specials do I want as a
George Carlin did ten that's amazing
I mean had ten specials I said man if I
can get close to ten and have a
catalogue of common events that's on par
with George Carlin that'd be an amazing
tap out man
because that man did some amazing stuff
and I'm a student so I've seen it I've
watched it cab what do you want your
legacy to be I'm I'm trying to build
something for me it's not about what
other people think it's not about what
other people have to say ultimately
everybody's gonna have an opinion that's
where we live it and yeah I don't you
know I compete we have to wrap up the
TARDIS to give other press but they tell
you not incompetent
one spot for one comedian no there's a
million [ __ ] but netflix is doing 52
specials this year I want a week unreal
I mean it's just 50 spot and you can
also tell it Kevin's being legit because
I think the people who have that
attitude are people that you find end up
hanging out with people they're even
more successful than they aren't is that
today relate to that so they're learning
from and so when you see you you hanging
out with jay-z hanging out with the
Rockettes like because you're not it's
not that time that you're not hanging
around you're not jealous of these
people and you sit around yourself with
people that say can motivate and inspire
you to go above and beyond yeah and
that's what I love about the
relationships that I have man I mean
look ultimately I can say this people
and I really want you understand this
it's a good book it's a really good book
I put my blood sweat and tears into this
book these stories are real but I'm
telling this story because I want people
to take this information and apply it to
themselves not to say that my story
should be your story it's just to say
that the will and want to win and to be
successful comes from within you and
you're going to hear know a lot but when
you finally hear that word yes it's
going to be so worth it and it's going
to make you understand that you can hear
it's so much more and go above and
beyond in creating opportunities for
yourself to create your goals not an
easy road and to mate and I'll give you
a couple of the the book signings
Kevin's doing there will be a line so
just get there early tonight Barnes and
Noble and Union Square at 7 o'clock then
Wednesday if you're from Philly the free
library Thursday he's going to be in
Washington DC and I'm guessing on your
Twitter and your website we'll have all
of these dates but he's got Miami Friday
Saturday Houston Sunday Minneapolis and
the Grove Monday the 12th at Barnes &
Noble in Los Angeles and having read 90%
of this book in like a very short period
of time I really is great I'm happy for
you man and reading I didn't know what
to expect I figure it'll be decent but
it was it was [ __ ] really great man
great money there's so much stuff I
didn't know about you and it's
interesting to see where you come from
because it explains everything and a lot
of violence and it just it's a great
book I mean a Bendis book so
congratulations maybe the lab to me Jim
nothing but love for me I'm happy I love
seeing this to me Joe saying no
yeah yeah